i want to go back to your thing but you
started with crony capitalism i mean you
didn't say those words but that's really
what we're talking about is 100
right okay okay don't yell at me you'll
get your applause break in a minute
i feel the night i feel a nice bar fight
breaking it
but i would defend capitalism i feel
like there's a flirtation now on the
left
because people don't read history they
don't know what happened before they
just live by slogans
and they don't understand
communism we tried it it wasn't that
long ago
just too long ago if you have that idea
in your head well i wasn't alive for it
so i shouldn't know about it
well maybe you should because we did try
it
and it's i would say communism is worse
than crony capitalism even crony
capitalism better than communism
would you agree with that professor
capitalism is hands down the best system
of its kind what young people are seeing
today it's not capitalism we have rugged
individualism on the way up
and then we have we're all in this
together on the way down and we have
socialism
capitalism on the way up where five ceos
of airline companies make 150 million
bucks use all their excess cash flow to
buy back stocks so they can artificially
inflate
their own compensation and then
gets real and a pandemic comes and they
don't have any money and all of a sudden
we're in this together
when you have capitalism on the way up
and you have
socialism on the way down i'm not done
yet and then you have socialism on the
way down
that's not capitalism or socialism it is
cronyism it is the worst of all worlds
capitalism
capitalism is full-body contact violence
at a corporate level so we can create
prosperity and progress
that rests on a bed of empathy we have
flipped the script here
we need to be more loving and empathetic
with people and more harsh on companies
capitalism we are protecting
we should be protecting people not
companies delta
burn baby burn yeah
oh my god all right bill you got a
ringer in here
[Applause]
i would like to make a prediction right
now before this show is over sir you
will be the governor of new york state i
believe because
i second that prediction sir
they're looking for one and we know you
got the speech ready
let's start bill uh i'll just say
my opinion on those things is sometimes
we make too much out of definitions you
know
and these things can be debated
philosophically
and that sort of thing but in the
practical like for instance capitalism
isn't even in our constitution that word
that
isn't in the constitution right you know
but our country
since i would say teddy roosevelt we've
expanded what capitalism
and the government's role in trade is
you know
and during the new deal we redefined the
government's role
with the person you know the with social
security the government can
can intervene directly with people you
know and since then we've had
not a p we've never had a pure form of
capitalism for a good 150 years
okay but it's always been expanding and
redefining itself and now
with uh the payments with the stimulus
payments once again we're expanding the
role of government and how
how people feel about that role of the
government directly in people's lives
you know yeah okay but again just to i
got my own
buzz just see that bill i got my own
[Applause]
applause
you